good
morning millennials or should i say
bonjour
no
bonjour no ciao millennials i still
don't know italian millennials
you clearly didn't study i was trying so
hard and all i could
really say to everyone was
which is literally what you say like as
you're falling asleep i'm like well no
not day over what does that mean good
night like it's good night but it's
really reserved for like when you're
actually going like a good night moon
yeah literally
so i learned no italian on my trip but
i'm back i'm so glad to be back in
america you know
this happens to me when i travel abroad
which i never do um i get really into it
like i was so living for
the culture the food the people like
learning all about different things that
customs you were really
being like a tourist girly and when ben
was here and we need to recap his time
of beyond the tea he was feeling so rdh
because he's like whenever claudia and i
go on vacation like we sit on the beach
all day and she doesn't want to like
tour i know and then you were spotted at
museums trevi fountain the college
landmarks can i explain myself sure you
have a lot to explain i have some
explaining to do first of all
i was with like all my friends and like
that's what they wanted to do so what it
was either sit at the hotel by myself or
be tortured and dragged around to every
like landmark in rome i did what i had
to do to survive first of all
second of all that what ben said is 100
true like but when i'm with ben like i
want to enjoy my life like even though
going to other places and seeing all
they have to offer is really cool but
it's also part treacher like so hot
literally couldn't stop walking my feet
my feet are still killing me like it's a
lot of work so when i'm on vacation i
really choose to enjoy myself but this
was like an educational trip yeah and i
never been to rome before i might not
ever go again so you do what you have to
do you know i didn't do the vatican
because like i literally didn't have it
in me like i was dead did your friends
do the vatican no oh
i didn't like skip the vatican i just
didn't go okay i mean they just didn't
go it wasn't on the itinerary so when it
comes to ben i hear him i literally had
no choice it was these were my options
like
hang with with my group a friend who i
haven't seen it forever we had such a
good time but like interspersed with
treacherous torture or sit in the hotel
by myself all day like those were my
options that's really sad so now but do
you feel like now
that when you travel you might
do more cultural things like yeah i
really did enjoy a lot of my time
especially when i discovered that i
didn't have to walk everywhere i could
scooter and they have lime they have
bird and it was
i'm telling you like i know it might not
work in new york but like oh my god it
was so amazing like you really cover so
much more
ground ground when you're on it you have
so much fun like i almost got hit by a
bus but it was all fun you know yeah
that's exciting i know that they're
outlawed in new york those scooters i
don't fully understand why it wouldn't
work in new york i would like a better
explanation me too because we're a very
bike friendly city we have bike lanes
and if you can do it in rome they drive
like [ __ ] nuts if you could do it in
rome you could do it anywhere yeah but
you know i was so i was really getting
like immersed in the culture like trying
to be like an italian girly
and whenever i travel abroad like there
is this
unmatched sense of relief when i come
back to america like all the comforts
you know i'm such a creature of habit
all the comforts that i have you know
things that i'm used to air conditioning
diet coke like these are things these
are not italian values but these are
core american values and like when i
just i could feel myself entering on the
plane like american airspace and it was
just like i'm telling you like there's
nothing like america like italy was
gorgeous
there's nothing like america and then
like towards the end of my trip i was
really starting to get resentful of
italians because it's like you know
everyone hates americans like you're big
dumb americans like oh and like that was
us we were traveling in groups looking
at our phones i didn't know where to go
and it's like it was funny but then i'm
like you know what i'm a proud american
like leave me alone like i was just
getting annoyed with like everyone being
like oh the americans are here like yeah
i'm [ __ ] american and i'm [ __ ]
proud [ __ ] okay we have diet coke and
you don't like okay you think you're so
great you think it's all right so i
started to feel like this resentment and
then i knew it was time to go home um
and i just can't put into words like how
much i love being home even though it's
an amazing trip like first of all
getting to see my friends from high
school who i like never get to see me
spend like like a whole five days
together it was awesome the wedding was
just
um it was gorgeous and it was just
it was such a happy weekend and i'm so
happy to be home but so happy that i
went and it was really um like a once in
a lifetime experience i would say wow
i'm so glad for you i'm so glad that you
went we had a great time here
i heard you know every day was something
different he's just you know i know for
you it's not your co-host of choice no
but for me it's just a totally different
energy well the feedback thus far has
been like ben and claudia
ben and jackie yes because we're just
like it's it's just different i mean i
understand i wouldn't want to do it with
your husband like claudia and zach
yes yeah yeah so it was it was good i'm
glad that it all worked out that you had
such a great fabulous time you looked so
wonderful thank you so much so fabulous
italian did you see my tick tocks
of course not unless you posted them to
your store i did
i saw the one of you flying to get real
pasta
what was that about oh yeah the drink
how sick were those cups yeah really
cool and then did someone say beveragino
do you see that one i don't think so
i'll show you later you're really
missing out okay sorry i feel like i
really put the content first you know i
was really being very content minded
content driven content driven
um and i also just wanted to share one
crazy thing that happened i forgot to
tell you
so
the wedding was like really so
unbelievably sickeningly gorgeous and it
was up this like not a cliff but like of
this mountain so you could overlook all
of rome and
we're going to the wedding my friend
rachel you know her grandparents were
holocaust survivors and she met this
italian man it's just like this gorgeous
jewish story a global jewish moment you
know
and we're on the way to the wedding and
literally first of all the graffiti in
rome is so bad they should really do
something about it like on these old
historic buildings that were literally
around three four hundred years ago like
what are you doing like it's disgusting
yeah
but we're on this cliff and as we're
going up
there's swastikas everywhere
jews are assassins i'm like what the
[ __ ] and it's like it's very clear to me
like we're going to this beautiful
jewish wedding the granddaughter of
holocaust survivors and we're sitting
here with our swastikas i'm like this is
[ __ ] oh my god it was crazy actually
never saw so much anti-semitic jewish
gravity in my life that's really scary i
know
so i was just like what is this honey it
was not it what is this honey geez i
know and also the graffiti it's like
they really should do something about it
because like in new york like the
graffiti on like dirty old buildings
like whatever it actually looks better
after they graffiti it i don't know but
like these gorgeous old like i don't
know what to call them like buildings
like brown stones like no and they're
landmarks yeah and there's so much
graffiti in rome it's crazy yeah and
it's more it's like centuries old
because here everything is max 300 years
old but there it's like you know super
the coliseum let's talk about the
coliseum okay
and i just want to talk about the food
in italy okay
coliseum first what
is your take my take on the colosseum
and it could have been that i was so
violently hungover and so hot i sweat
through my sweater like i was miserable
your sweater but like okay so i got to
the costume we pulled up in the taxi and
i took this gorgeous photo of the
outside of the colosseum
should have went home after that okay
because you know what's in the inside of
the coliseum
dirt yeah lots of [ __ ] dirt and we
had this actually amazing tour guide who
was like giving a lot of like the jewish
history of the coliseum and she was full
of interesting factoids but i was just
like i'm not really like a tour girl and
like paired with the hangover and the
sun
i was like i came out of bed like to see
this like they've done a good job of
like preserving it and it's really
interesting like you would have loved it
like you know what they used to do at
the coliseum they would like kill each
other like why am i here i'm like this
is sad and then like
the tour guy was saying we know but then
the barbarians came and i like felt
stupid i'm like who are the barbarians
like i don't know what the hell she was
talking about but i'm like oh no the
barbarians and then i'm like you guys
sound like the barbarians like you were
literally killing each other in the
gladiator for entertainment for
entertainment and then the animals got
involved and i'm like leave the animals
alone they would have like the animals
thrown in with a bunch of gladiators i'm
like
okay
that's bad and i was just like
i was very confused about the history
because i'm not really a history buff
she was like talking about these time
periods and i'm like when is this like
so she said 70 a.d
that is really cool that there's still a
building standing from 70 a.d like it's
sickening for sure i just like was not
in the right headspace and i don't mean
to offend like italian culture at all it
was just like
it was a lot of dirt you know like a lot
of hype and then you go inside and it's
like
you know i think that's what most people
expect to find there maybe you just
weren't briefed i don't know i was ready
for like a paulo and isabella show you
know i thought it was like a full-blown
arena yeah but they still do stuff there
like no no no no no you go in like the
center of like where all the sand
actually i just learned something very
interesting so in the arena
the whole floor where everyone would
fight think you know
pink beyonce and britney spears from the
pepsi commercial of course
it's it's um made of sand yeah and
that's why they call arenas arenas
because the latin word for sand is like
arena or something you know so i did
learn something actually very
interesting look at you with the factoid
yes and here's another fact what i
learned at the coliseum a lot of the
materials
that i'm sorry i just remembered
something funny um a lot of the
materials that were used to build the
colosseum and like keep it up they were
taken from other places so when the beta
meat dash was destroyed by the romans
the jewish temple
they took the materials into the
coliseum so when you know like years ago
when they were unearthing parts of the
coliseum they found materials from the
beta mcdosh the old shul
that had maps of jerusalem on them
so we're very much the jewish people
like we're a part of the coliseum's
history for sure for sure yeah we have
like a jewish tour guide because you
know we have to make everything about
ourselves no but the jews like are you
know a fixture throughout history so
there's always there's always a jewish
element in the history yeah so it was
really interesting where were the jews
hiding where were the jews being kicked
out of like it was really interesting i
was just like so for clamped like my
body my body still is like
what did you do i've never moved that
much in my whole life what was your step
count ten thousand at least every day
maybe more but the scooter didn't count
my i was scootering like for miles you
know
um
but here's the other thing not only did
i walk so much like yes i had pasta for
every single meal and snack but i don't
know like the pastor italy's like made
of vegetables you know what i mean it's
like having a salad in america in my
opinion like it's not bad for you that's
what they say though no just because the
way that it's made it's like
not it's not like eating
what's the brand we use here like to
chico
barilla
yeah
de chico is one that's what i know
so i bought them and it's the same
barilla is the best yeah she went to the
barilla factory gorilla's foolproof no
and so like the pasta in italy is
healthier so you're eating salads every
day no like it was literally the
healthiest i've ever eaten in my life
and i ate so much possibly was it
delicious so yes the like i from what
i've learned in my time in rome they're
like official like they're known for
their kachowi pepe okay but you're not a
pepe girl and i had it and like it was
fine i just really don't like kachowi
pepe you don't like cacho or pepe no not
at all it's like grown up like serious
mac and cheese like spicy with pepper
and i'm like just give me the craft you
know yeah um but i had so much spaghetti
crafty pepe
craftio for sure
i had so much spaghetti pomodoro which
is like my meal of choice and then like
when you say pomodoro they know you're
american that's like not it they're like
speaking of tomato and basil i'm like
yeah sure like they hate the waiters
hated us like here's a great story for
you
i went to lunch with you know abe who
did a great job of taking all my
pictures he did he got the angles he got
the lighting and he wanted a nice tea
and the guy was like we have peach i was
like oh my god that sounds so good he's
like but is it like
like snapple or like
fresh you know
and it was which was a dumb question
cause like we're in italy it's fresh
yeah and the guy was like so offended he
was like he's fresh and we're like oh
great okay
you know what wasn't such a dumb
question it came in a bottle of like the
italian snapple i don't know what brand
it looked like an honest tea yeah
this like one because we we pretty much
exclusively spoke english one wherever i
went i was like oh sweet spaghetti
pomodoro they don't have it at every
restaurant and even look at the menu it
was in italian like everywhere we went
like the waiters just like thought we
were dumb ugly fat jewish americans and
like towards the end like it started to
chip away at me i was like at first i'm
like yeah that's me i'm an american and
then as it went on i'm like you know
what i'm a proud american like i believe
yeah and so i believe in being fat 100
and dumb and so you know what i was
starting to feel like a lot of
resentment on my way out of italy okay
i'm glad that you left before it boiled
over but a gorgeous city a gorgeous time
was had by all and you know what they
don't have in italy lacroix so you're
back
there's nothing like a liquid
when you've been off the sauce for six
days i look cory biermann actually
i
i had so much water because pellegrino
like is like
mother's milk there right and i was
thinking i should have went to the
pellegrino factory in this to the land
yeah 100 and they don't have diet coke
yeah and then when you order pellegrino
you're like speaking the language oh
yeah so i got really good at the accent
oh also i know how to say grazie grazie
yeah but then also if you really mean it
a thousand thank yous and then prego
which is like of course i think
okay yeah so it was amazing and also i
stayed at the saint regis if you're
going to rome what a spectacular palace
nice
gorgeous
wonderful she was great i'm so glad i
wanted to do any shopping anything for
me anything for my birthday oh such a
good question i tried so hard to shop
and do you go to fendi roma i went to
fenty roma and i said oh they hated me
in there too i was like i have credit at
the store in new york can i use it
because ben got me like a really [ __ ]
ugly purse for my birthday and i've just
like been sitting on this credit waiting
to find something that i like yeah and
the guy was like no i'm like gotta go
like
the thing is i tried so hard to shop
first of all i packed so incorrectly it
is so hot there jackie it's 60 degrees
okay you go outside in the sun you're so
i think you're close to the equator yeah
oh my god i could have died it was so
hot so then when you're walking around
you go into the store they're worse in
italy than they are in america with the
masks and i'm you know of course don't
want to spread coped but i'm like sir i
cannot shop in here i'm like it's so
unpleasant they don't believe in air
conditioning it's so hot outside it's so
hot it's hotter in the stores and the
mask and they don't like if it slips a
little they're like hey i go and i'm
like you know what this is not an
environment for me to drop money like i
want to be comfortable yeah i tried on
multiple occasions i almost bought
something in prada but you know what i
wasn't feeling it and i was just like
i'm i want to spend money because like
i'm in rome but like like if there's
nothing i'm feeling yeah i got new
glasses no it has to be the right
environment i got new um drinking
glasses from like some really sick store
that you would have loved and i think
you're gonna be like jealous of my cups
oh interesting yeah but i didn't i was
like disappointed in my but you didn't
bring back a gift for me even though i
might have brought back a gift for you
and like presented to you on the show no
i know i i really tried so very hard
okay
and there wasn't like anything that like
made me think of you you know okay i'm
being totally honest even at bendy by
the way fendi skims have you seen of
course i have did you talk about it
yesterday yes with ben and
it's so sickening we don't need to go
over it again but i'm so excited so
excited everything looks deeply cool and
stylish i was hoping that like since it
was with skims it would be like a lower
price price point but no not skims but
like maybe somewhere in the middle no
but it's fendi materials i will be
getting the bomber jacket i will be
attempting to get um the dress that's
like the one that she's wearing on the
cover of the wall street journal because
i think that would look nice with a bump
i think so too and
there was something else but i mean i'll
really take what i can get you know and
i want the tights
of course yes
yes it's very exciting very very
exciting what else did i miss that you
guys talked about i haven't had time to
catch up on the show
terrible
terrible
what the [ __ ] happened i don't know and
did you hear that the uh did you hear
the 911 call
i didn't hear it i it was on tick tock
like so
i just thought it was
really first of all this literally may
be the saddest thing i've heard ever um
and when the
the police 911 operator was like was it
a blank or a real gun like just asking
for details the woman was like i'm not
at liberty to say
what does that mean
i don't know i feel so bad for alec
baldwin like that's terrible it's
terrible it's a terrible story and i
feel even worse for the woman who died
in her family
oh my god that was shocking
and the movie is about an accidental
death the movie that they're filming is
it yeah
are they going to keep doing the movie
great question who wants to go see that
i think it's i think that's the end it's
lights out for the film i think it as it
should be yeah what else did you talk
about
brian laundry dead brian laundry
suspicious potentially dead gentle yeah
you know a lot of people have been like
conspiracy theorizing this whole thing
and the whole time i was like you know
what
i don't think it's that
conspiracy written
this is making me question yeah a lot of
people are suss about it but we're still
like waiting to see
and then also ben insisted we bring back
toast movie of the weekend i saw because
he just like really wanted some homework
and i was like okay i'm not gonna make
you watch beverly hills reunion so we
watch the britney murphy documentary
it was so good i tried to download it on
hbo max on the way home for the flight
there's no hbo max in italy so i
couldn't even download the app on my
ipad just another reason you had to get
home 100
um one last thing
last night i watched real housewives of
beverly hills reunion that i missed just
because i didn't want to be like so
behind and i don't know what you had to
say about it and also watch curb your
enthusiasm but i thought that erica did
like a sickening job what i said was
erica is clawing her way back and there
is a clear path don't know if it will be
the one she goes down at the end of the
day but she is if she i said if she had
to give herself a grade this was
obviously a very tall task for her she
it's an a
yeah and you know the only thing that i
feel like i really like um with all the
stuff the legal stuff like what she's
telling me i believe like it sounds like
it's real where she loses me when she's
so mean to everyone and i think that
this week is where she like lashes out
at sutton and just like lashes out at
everyone like he doesn't apologize or at
least own the fact like i'm going
through a hard time i'm sorry i've been
acting like an animal that's the one
thing i wish she did and she didn't do
and i think she digs herself in a little
deeper in the next two episodes that's
really where she's really bothering me
the only part of the story that doesn't
add up that i can't really you know go
out on a limb for and just give her the
benefit of the doubt is the timing of
when she filed for divorce from tom of
course based on saying i was going to
hold his hand till he died he starts
mentally declining and yet you divorcing
him has nothing to do with the major
lawsuits that are coming out a week
later yeah no 100 and she didn't answer
that question she never talked about all
the pictures she took at the crime scene
of not crime scene of the car scene when
it flipped and how she called all the
doctors the orthopedic surgeon yeah yeah
so i thought though it was a great
performance by erica i'm not gonna lie i
had the same thought it felt like
watching a presidential debate you know
how you come out of the debate being
like who won
who do you think i like eric was the
clear winner yeah no she is
she's coming back out and when kathy
hilton cried i cried the world cried the
world cried it was so sad yeah i [ __ ]
she's so cute she's so cute yeah
so yeah i'm pretty caught up i watched
curb your enthusiasm i spoke to you
about it i was actually um like larry
david could just like shart and i would
be like that is brilliant
it was like a fine regular episode of
curb but like coming off this
insane pandemic we've just been through
you know that larry would have like the
most hilarious reaction to like the
masks and like the six feet and it's
literally of all the shows i've ever
watched every time they bring up cobin i
can't like
it's so triggering for me this is the
one show i wanted to do and they didn't
even do it yeah they mentioned one thing
about the purell there was no kovid like
i wanna i thought he came back because
of clovid you should actually watch this
episode of the morning toast from
yesterday because there's a girl one of
the hosts jackie said everything
gorgeous oh yeah and she was looking
really great yesterday she was she was
and she's saying everything you're
thinking okay
down to like the funny storylines and
the unfunny ones i was so disappointed
don't worry like your voice was
heard heard because i had this exact
same thoughts okay good and i converted
ben to agreeing with me because when he
came into the studio he was like it was
so good and then by the end he was like
do you better laugh that's so funny
because when i got into bed last night
i'm like have you seen kerb he's like
yeah i'm like oh can i watch it he was
like yeah i'll watch it again it was you
know very uh so you really did change
his mind
i ruined it for him yeah 100 that's
really funny
um okay like that was really all i had
to unload like how was how was life
without me here
was no it was it was nice and quiet and
it was just like it's nice to switch
things up because then we miss you and
then when you're back it's so exciting
yeah absence makes the heart grow fonder
totally so no it was pretty quiet it was
just a lot of bend time i watched the
show succession while you were gone
and i finished i'm all caught up now
everyone and i need to know where people
stand are are people this isn't a
spoiler because it's team logan or team
kendall because i know where i stand i
just need to like i'm just wondering if
i'm the outlier i have something to tell
you okay
i met
in italy
one
italian toaster
you met
an italian toaster a piece of garlic
bread no like i met
a bunch of like americans in rome like a
couple were staying at my hotel like
toasters from but in the bathroom at the
club there was a fully
a fully italian fully italian italian
toaster and you're and you're telling me
it was an italian camper no no no no no
she was a grown woman
interesting how was she she was
sickening i couldn't believe it like
because i never like i had met a bunch
of people and they were like i love the
toast i'm like where are you from texas
you know like like regular toasters just
on vacation yeah this was a toaster in
her homeland in the motherland yeah it
was shocking
wow well shout out to you yeah ciao
millennial
no
i don't know you don't know no because
no buena notte is good night so buena
morning
millennials
just watch this okay
okay
good morning in italian
what'd your no no wait
wait buongiorno that's what i said i
know all this from my time doing
research as italian camper bonjour no
millennials oh my god so good
okay i think without further ado we
should get into the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast and today's episode is brought to
you by bruce and i didn't have mine in
italy and i felt and we can smell it
from here i felt such a difference i
can't lie like with the hotel toothbrush
it was not it the best electric
toothbrush on the market is bruce if
you've been looking to get into an
electric toothbrush but don't want to
spend over 200 which is what some
electric toothbrushes cost which is
insane bruce is the most affordable the
most aesthetically pleasing and the most
effective in my opinion so the bruce
comes with six unique modes to customize
your brushing experience the battery
life lasts four weeks it comes with a
magnetic charging stand and a compact
travel case that i did not use i forgot
and they also have a subscription
program because even though it's
electric you should still change your
brush head every six months for optimal
dental hygiene um so they will
ship you a new replacement head every
six months so you're never stuck using a
worn down brush head if you join their
subscription program the design is very
sleek it has a modern aesthetically
pleasing design it comes in trend driven
seasonal colors and it looks great on
your bathroom counter and i can attest
to that as kanjaki get 15 off your bruce
toothbrush kit and the refill plan when
you use promo code toast at bruce.com
toast that's 15 off using promo code
toast at b-r-u-u-s-h-dot-com
toast if you don't have a bruce yet like
what are you doing
anniversary in two days
see you guys then
okay first story big news dave chappelle
speaks out in the wake of the netflix
stand up special backlash he says i said
what i said dave chappelle is standing
by his netflix stand-up special the
closer but says that he's open to a
discussion with the lgbtq community
about concerns he was perpetuating
transphobia days after the comedians rep
told people that he was willing to speak
with the streamers employees about the
controversy the comedian extended the
offer to any transgender person who
wanted to sit down with him although he
did have a few conditions he said it was
said in the press that i was invited to
speak to the transgender employees of
netflix and i refused that is not true
he said if they invited me i would have
accepted it although i'm confused about
what we're speaking about i said what i
said and boy i heard what you said my
god how could i not you said you want a
safe working environment at netflix well
it seems like i'm the only one that
can't go to the office anymore
so
this has been an ongoing story since his
special came out yeah you know like
every time he releases a special there
is like a hoopla and then it ties down
but this like won't die down because it
was a big protest outside the netflix
employees walked out in solidarity
against the special i guess they want
the specialty taken down they want
an apology
so here's the thing and i think that
there's a few important things to note
first is that i do think a lot of okay
so here's the thing sorry i want to
start from scratch because i changed my
mind okay one i watch a special yes me
too about half of it okay maybe more
um and there were two jokes about jews
that i really did not like like i really
was
not into so you know what i did
i turned off the special
and then i went on with my life yeah and
i don't know i just didn't feel like
protesting i think that like
when it comes to comedy
i don't know it's definitely a gray area
for me and i feel like i haven't heard
anyone making any outrage about the
anti-semitism
but you know what like yeah bothered me
did i feel like he should be canceled
and stripped of all of his accolades and
his movie should be taken out of film
festivals no because it's a joke and yes
i didn't like it but it's a joke like
it's a joke and so
i don't know i don't really feel like
getting involved in this because it's
like dave chappelle's mess and i want
people to be like can't believe
so honestly like i don't even want to
talk about it because like you might not
agree with me you might might agree with
me i watched a special
and i stopped it halfway and that was it
you know yeah because you didn't like
what you heard no but you didn't stage a
protest but you're not calling for it to
be taken down no and you know what i
actually did really want to see his
documentary about those shows that he
did during covid i thought they were
that whole concept and his neighbor's
cornfield was like super interesting i'm
sure the documentary was so good the
documentary is now being pulled from
every major festival that it was um
submitted to or accepted into
and you know when you're canceled
i think we can speak to this quite well
you do
what you can so he's now selling his own
tickets screening it himself and that's
kind of the beauty of being someone with
a platform is that while it's great to
have a netflix special to have your
movie at toronto film festival you don't
need it like you could get just as many
eyeballs on it if you really see
yourself yeah and i don't think he's
canceled i think this is really an
inflection point because netflix and the
ceo of netflix is still standing by him
they won't they haven't taken down the
special i think that would be the
cancellation yeah and it really is a
part of a larger conversation that's
been ongoing for years and especially
one about canceled culture and two about
comedy comedy and you say that it's a
gray area but i actually think
i think it's very black and white and i
think that
we're needing to decide now yeah are we
are we making jokes that are offensive
or are we not or are we not now i am
team
i'm team jokes i'm team
free speech and i think even though i
the special i finished it it
gave me a pit it made me really sad for
like the whole day yeah because i found
it to be anti-semitic and i really
really didn't like those the running gym
there was like a running joke in the
entire special event if you've seen it
then you know what it's a space jews
joke i can't even it really it bothered
me it really hurt my feelings me too
but
it's it's his special it's his jokes
it's his prerogative and if i don't like
it then i'm gonna i'm gonna go move on
yeah
and that's what i did same you know so i
it's
it's a sticky situation yes you're 100
right this is a conversation we've been
having for years where people keep
you know getting into pickles where it's
like in this in the space of comedy and
i'm not talking about other situations
when somebody you know says something
bad on a podcast not trying to be funny
just like
i'm not talking about situations like
that i'm talking about in traditional
stand-up comedy comedy specials
tv shows that are funny
where do we land with this whole thing
because we're living in a very kind of
politically correct time
especially on the internet
so
when comedy is so the con like the
complete contrast of that
personally i find it refreshing even if
i don't like every joke that i hear
it does feel like a lot of times in this
day and age like everything you say is
just watched and you have to be so
careful with your words if you even not
even if you have a platform at work
anywhere you are like we we don't really
allow people to like you know misspeak
anymore um
and so for me that contrast and comedy
it's like so refreshing it's just like
say whatever you want that's always what
comedy's been dave chappelle is this
like old school comedian so while i
didn't love everything i heard on the
special
i just
you know moved on from it yeah and i
still like like dave chappelle i just
don't like those jokes yeah
i think that's fair i think it's fair
too i mean everybody obviously has a
different take on it
and i but i do think that this is a very
a big moment it's a it's it's a
crossroads it's a defining moment and
like because you need to decide as a
culture like are we going to joke about
stuff or are we really the last comic
standing who will go there on anything
yeah and he's he will he'll never you
know release an apology he'll never back
down from uh and you know i think what's
important is first of all i know a lot
of people who are upset about the
special like have not watched it because
there is this underlying context of like
who gets to be offended and who doesn't
get to be offended and i think one of
the messages from what i saw of the
special is like there's selective
outrage and so certain communities you
know are entitled to outrage and certain
or not and like a lot of people you know
nobody was you know outraged when dave
chapel was making fun of his own
community um
or any other community he's made fun of
everyone he's an equal opportunity
comedian so it's like what he said in
the special is actually kind of playing
out in the public space right now right
right it's it's an it's really this is a
very interesting social experiment yeah
and and moment yeah and we'll we'll see
where it goes from here if they do wind
up sitting down if they agreed his terms
of watching the special and admitting
that hannah gatsby isn't funny yes that
was part of his that was part of his
terms if they want to meet with him they
have to watch a special
and
meet him at a place of his choosing at
the time of his choosing and admit that
hannah gadsby isn't funny and i can't
lie i don't know who that is so i don't
know if she's funny or not i know who
she is but i haven't spent time with her
comedy well she had a netflix special
that um
she recently posted on instagram she was
very upset about this dave chappelle she
released this like very harsh
you know statement towards the ceo of
netflix towards netflix in general and
what i found to be really interesting
was the comedians fighting in the in the
comment section there was a whole thread
of hannah gadsby
michelle wolf and michael che like
arguing about like where's the line in
comedy is and michelle wolf and michael
che was like there isn't a line yeah
there can't be a line because we
disagreed in the comments where is the
where does she say the line is she i
don't remember because there it just
doesn't
no it's like are there there isn't like
can there even be a line yeah and john
stewart came out in support of dave
chappelle
who basically was like his intention is
obviously never to like hurt people it's
a social commentary yeah um so i do
think it's really interesting to hear
from like big comedians a lot of them
are not speaking out but the ones that
are i'm interested to hear what they
have to say yeah a lot of them are not
speaking out well of course not because
in this day and age if you say something
even you go down with the ship no then
you're transphobic yeah when that might
not be the case at all and it's probably
not the case so i think i didn't even
want to talk about this because like
i i hated the special but i don't think
it should be taken down and i don't
think dave chappelle should be burned at
the stake but i still i thought this
special was terrible how about that but
i think you should be allowed to say
that i do yeah i hear you like i didn't
even laugh i was so mad
yeah but it's also like this thing this
day dave chabel has this thing inside of
him where it's like he's gonna say the
craziest [ __ ]
because he believes in the right to say
to be able to not necessarily because he
believes it right and i think that that
is important i agree so it's very
extreme
and it's at the expense of some of us
but i don't know it just
the special bothered me but dave
chappelle doesn't bother me if that
makes sense yeah and i'm sorry if you
disagree with me like please don't
cancel me i'm just not in the mood
i've had such a long travel day i was on
the plane for 10 hours yesterday
yeah it was a treacherous flight but
they did serve a cheese pizza have you
ever had that oh my god when i came back
from
would you fly delta united oh okay no
when i flew back from france they gave
me like a a pizza in a box like oh it
was it was like a pizza burrito almost
okay that's not what i got i got and you
know she woke me up for lunch and i was
like slightly pissed and she's like i
have a cheese pizza i'm like give it i'm
your girl it was almost like a camp
pizza it was like perfectly circular it
was so delicious
it was a personal crunch a personal
pizza like a kid's pizza yes it was so
good and i was you know i'm i'm really
slowly turning and when it comes to like
business class i'm really turning into
united girly like don't sleep on it i'm
telling you they have the best food in
united polaris interesting yeah and just
gorgeous service wow you love to see it
except i did have like an interaction
yesterday with a flight attendant that
made me like really annoyed i told you
about it yeah you did and i don't know
if people are gonna agree with me but
like i was it was the earliest flight i
was so tired
i passed out on the flight and i'm
wearing you know an eye mask over my
eyes and my mask and
i must have been asleep for like an hour
and somebody's like scratching my back
like waking me up like in a sweet
maternal way like hey and i looked at my
eye mask like who the [ __ ] is waking me
up and she's like can you pull your mask
over your nose
okay yes my mask in my sleep not my
fault i fell asleep with it on my nose
had slid down now
was there anyone within 12 feet of me no
because i was in an individual
business classy not that people in
business class don't have to wear masks
that's not what i'm saying i'm just
saying look scientifically
scientifically there was nobody within
12 feet of me i was under a blanket with
an eye mask and a face mask a sliver of
my nose was showing
she really had to wake me up i know
she's just doing her job and i'm not
it's not that i'm not blaming her it's
about the circumstances yeah i was so if
i wasn't able to fall back asleep i
swear to god i would have burned the
plane down like
i was so angry i was just like i really
respect the hustle like you doing your
job it's not about the flight attendant
i swear
i just felt like it was really uncool of
her like for real she couldn't have just
let it slide for like forever
and she didn't see that little nose i
know and have such a little nose that's
why you have to sleep like
cover your face no just put the blanket
you gotta dab on them literally i was
yeah no i need to face the window
i was i was not facing the aisle i was
facing a window i was on my side how
about that i don't know how she even saw
my nose what was she doing so close to
me she was violating she
[Music]
i'm kidding but like honestly
it was so annoying i i wish i could have
seen my face when i realized that's why
she woke me up i'm like
what
it's just like no way
no way did you do this yeah
it was [ __ ] crazy that's crazy we're
living in such [ __ ] crazy times if
you saw the hoops side to jump through
to get to italy like the test the
vaccine that's the other portals so you
had to have a negative test okay so to
come to fly yeah so on my way there i
had a negative test and a vaccination
card yeah on my way back i had gotten a
test in italy and of course my
vaccination card and i was wearing them
so you're sitting on the plane with
everybody else on the plane who has a
negative test and a vaccination card and
your lethal nose is showing and you got
to wake up no it was so insane
and honestly the travel has become so
unenjoyable not because of the mask
honestly it doesn't bother me that much
anymore
literally running through italy trying
to get a covet test
in italian i finally get one they never
give me the results my friend margo fish
runs down to the pharmacy before shabbat
starts banging down the door like to
give us our results she doesn't know
italian it's just so complicated now to
travel these portals that you have to
and nobody tells you like you don't get
an email from your airline like hey
here's all the 11 things you have to do
you have to google it yourself like if
it wasn't for the pointsguy.com like i
wouldn't know what to do wow it's just
chaos okay so worth it though well i
have a story our next story was
hand-picked just for you i could have
shared it yesterday but i waited till
you came back because tar gal musa and
heather ray young are married and that's
the love that she's always dreamed of i
saw it on tick tock because they're both
like thirsty on tik tok and they use
these like over hyped like romantic
sounds and it's so cringy oh this is
their moment you know it's like every
like baking cupcakes they make a moment
out of that but like here they actually
have a wedding they're two celebrities
like this is it for them so
they were married on saturday night near
santa barbara they were surrounded by
family and friends including most of
heather's castmates from
selling sunset which is like coming back
like any day now yeah selling sunsets
coming back any day now so that's really
exciting christine was obviously not
there right
i don't think so i'm going to assume no
because she wasn't at any of the smaller
engagements was christina hack there
yes that's nice i think so
i think so you know what i actually
thought was a cute thing but i didn't
keep up with the hacks no me neither so
i but i saw a headline that her and her
new fiance were at universal after the
nuptials but does that mean after they
went i didn't actually i didn't see her
there didn't care enough can you google
it i didn't care enough to click okay
but i actually did see a cute little
tradition that they did because you know
there's a father-daughter dance at every
wedding if you have a dad
um
christina
heather ray danced with her dad while
tarek danced with his daughter it was
like really sweet i actually thought
that was cute oh that is cute i guess it
doesn't happen often no it's like if
you're making someone with kids who
happens to have a daughter right i
thought it was a really sweet um
idea like if anyone is getting married
and they have a daughter like i think
that's like something you should steal i
thought it was really cute wow a
compliment for the target that's my only
compliment also christina was not at the
wedding she was noticeably absent yeah i
mean i guess it's
not conventional for your ex-wife to be
at your wedding but i know sometimes
when like you have kids if you co-parent
very well you want it to be like this
copacetic but it's usually not yeah it's
so that's i've never really thought
about it but it's also like your ex-wife
is someone that you talk to like all the
time you know she's probably coming over
to the house in a few days to pick up
the kids and we just had this big event
and you weren't there no it's like rude
yeah especially because like they at
least pretend like they have a decent
i don't think that they do i think like
if i know if i know what i think i know
about the el moussa hack crew
it's no bueno got it
okay so maybe it's for the best so
heather ray young like looked like
exactly what i thought she was going to
look like and her wedding ended at 11 59
and she changed her instagram name at 12
o'clock like heather ray young and musa
oh no heather ray elmo but her at is
still heather young or whatever okay
heather ray young i'm sorry heather
rayal moussa
heather
heather no it's heather ray el moussa
yeah heather rayam okay so she's she
dropped a young but in her at like her
actual username is still heather right
now right i'm sure you know even she
can't move that quickly i love seeing
how fast people do that on instagram i
know i wonder
well most times like when it's like
people who i follow who are not
celebrities like they change their
handle really quickly but she just
changed her name which isn't a big lift
no changing your name your handle is
such a big deal yeah um and but i
actually so i used to think it was like
kind of like people who did it the next
day was like wow you've been waiting
like forever to change it but now i i
think it's actually i really like it
because i just immediately start
associating them with their new last
name yes
and the longer they go
with their old last name it's harder to
disassociate 100 and i think the perfect
but also when you're an influencer like
your name is your brand you have to be
very careful yeah so i actually think
that the person who did it perfectly is
lauren lane yeah and that might be
because like her new name is like such a
cutesy like instagrammer name yeah that
she's lauren lane to me yeah
and i love that name no formerly lauren
bushnell in case you don't know who
people who make the the jump
i always like then it really works okay
so you know taylor schrecker and taylor
johnny who got married but they can't
both be they they'll they'll be taylor's
on a human tail or donahue or taylor
striker and taylor trekker what do you
do in that situation you just leave it i
think you got to leave it yeah otherwise
they'll have the same name no how crazy
would that be if there were two like
taylor strikers running around yeah wow
i never thought of that i know me
neither and i was like why aren't you
guys changing your names and they're
like we can't i'm like why
yeah it took me like 20 minutes to
figure it out i'm like oh yeah you can't
yeah that's like if taylor lautner and
taylor swift got married right
wow
crazy or
you could have the opposite
ralph lauren's daughter married a girl
named lauren so she's lauren lauren even
though their real life name is lipschitz
but
lord ralph lauren's daughter sorry son
married a girl named lauren oh so then
she's born
even though lauren and loren lauren
loren and also lorena is not their last
name it's ralph lipschitz yeah um so
she's lauren love shits which is
adorable adorable like a jewish queen
you know yeah
okay are you ready for our next story is
it the next story that's brought you by
the psychology-based approach of noom it
is that is such a crazy coincidence
instead of setting strict rules numa is
going to empower you with knowledge to
build smarter more sustainable habits
and behaviors so if you're looking to
get in shape for whatever reason you
want to feel better you want your
clothes to fit better
whatever reason you have is your own
business um pneum is a really good
option they use a cognitive behavioral
approach where you'll focus on the why
instead of the what to change your
relationship with eating everyone's
journey is different so newman's
customizing programs for you based on
your personal goals whatever that might
be like i said like if you're looking to
feel better drop some extra pounds fit
into your clothes
with nume it's nourishing instead of
restrictive so no food is considered off
limits they keep eating foods they keep
they let you keep eating foods that you
love while learning to maintain a
healthier balance an off day with noob
is totally okay and it will not set you
off course they'll just gently help you
back on track they ask for 10 minutes of
your day each day to teach you about
your eating habits and check in on your
progress they also have one of the most
um world-renowned i would say food
databases in the world so when you are
tracking your food that's one of the
biggest benefits um they make it really
easy you don't have to input every
calorie right just search you know the
item that you're looking for and it it
gives you all the nutritional
information
so if you're just looking to
check out noom sign up for your trial
and get psychology-based support and
motivation to reach your goals at
noomnoom.com
thank you for that claudia it's a
pleasure
okay next up some news that i didn't
think i would care about but i really
but here we are but here we are katie
thurston and blake moines break up after
bachelorette engagement it is over for
katie and blake the bachelorette couple
whose engagement aired on the abc dating
series season 17 finale in august took
to social media on monday to announce
their breakup wow august i didn't even
realize it was that recent i thought it
was like june i have so many thoughts
they both posted the same statement that
was like so
cooked up by pr and you know not even
trying to hide it but where they used
all the bingo terms it is with mutual
love and respect that we have decided to
go our separate ways we are so grateful
for the moments of two months that we
shared together and the entire journey
that has unfolded this year but we
ultimately have concluded that we are
not compatible as life partners and it
is the most caring choice for both of us
to move forward blah blah blah what do
you think is the record for the shortest
bachelorette is it whitney and crystals
i was thinking whitney and crystals so i
don't know if i can do the math quickly
enough i think they were like six weeks
it was really fast when i saw this i was
thinking of that me too and so i
the i don't know why this shocks me so
much because it's like even if they're
not suitable soulmates like i would have
thought that they would have milked it a
little longer yeah me too because one
like if you go through your whole season
of the bachelor or the bachelorette and
you break up within two months no
offense it's a complete waste of time
it's a squandered opportunity you had 25
you know eligible people who were there
for you and you your picker was off
jackie you literally took the words
right out of my mouth what i was going
to say was like first of all
katie was the bachelorette that like
honestly nobody wanted and
now that her whole season was a failure
though
the entire process was a waste of time i
don't feel like okay so something so i
i'm thinking of like hannah brown here
because hannah brown hannah brown by the
way wandered her opportunity he's the
shortest engagement probably but yeah
because they broke up before after the
final rose but with hannah brown she was
so beloved that like she had this
amazing career after with the dancing
with the stars her instagram blew up
like she became so popular like it
wasn't even about the franchise also
like hannie doesn't have that hannah
brown followed her heart she was wronged
and that's why she like afterwards like
everyone's related to her rally in there
around her it's not that she chose
someone and they spent two months
together and realized they don't
actually like each other yeah she was
like she was conned and she didn't have
all the information and that's kind of
not her fault no of course not but what
i'm saying is i'm not saying that you
think that it is no but i'm saying so i
don't think that her season was how
could she have done it ever any
different i mean when you think of the
fact that she had tyler cameron like
right it's shocking i'm sorry you know
what she did she got conned but even
after her season people were so like
obsessed
that like it didn't even matter who she
ended up with like she was a bonafide
star you know i couldn't even see katie
being on the bachelor on the dancing
with the stars like i don't think she
she's not universally like like her
season was just like now especially
given the fact that they're broken up
but even if it wasn't it was just like
those random [ __ ] season like i also
think that's because you didn't watch
her season and maybe all the others so
everyone else is so topical i don't
watch
season i didn't watch hannah brown's
season either and still i feel this way
yeah no i think i'm no that was a fair
point you brought up but i don't want
you to round around you shut it right
down i'm a debunker i'm a mythbuster
that is really true so anyways i just
it's always shocking to me not that they
break up but that they're ready to admit
that it was a failure and they they
waste the opportunity of
when you're in a couple
even if you're not everyone's favorite
you're more relevant like yeah so
honestly it get i actually have a lot of
respect for it yeah i mean but that also
probably goes to show that these past
two months where the team were like that
was them you know faking it trying to be
like get them as long as they could yeah
yeah especially like with social media
you could just you know keep the charade
going for so long yeah the only other
thing that comes to mind is like ari
becca and lauren
and it's like they broke up obviously so
quickly because he knew that you know he
picked wrong but he
then remedied the situation and like
found love i wonder if they're like and
i always wonder this
for people who you know they clearly
picked the wrong person but they had a
great group of guys
is there anyone that you would want to
go out with now that's such a fair point
i think about that all the time i think
a lot of people were wondering that
about hannah brown like with her and
tyler's yeah like the pandemic together
but they made it clear that they were
just like really really good friends
which was just like kind of weird um no
that's a very fair point i'm sure that
there are everyone says this guy greg
from katie's season is yeah i remember
him a great a great guy but then i also
like saw headlines that he was like with
other bachelor nation girlies yeah yeah
so i don't know
no also just i could really talk about
that ari and lauren situation like for
days on end because i feel like they got
so much [ __ ]
um when i felt like
from the way i saw it ari did everything
right he made a mistake of course and
that's was a bad mistake to make but he
fixed it in a way that was right for him
was right for lauren and he broke up
with back on national television and she
became the bad threat and now she
doesn't have to work anymore she has a
podcast she went on paradise she's a
girly girl and she's fine yeah and you
know what she might not have had all of
that if it weren't for ari doing it so
publicly so i just want to say if he had
like waited the requisite two months and
it was irrelevant
he secretly reached out to lauren after
all the press like had moved on and it
was just like oh i'm dating someone else
for my season like peter and kelly right
right now and who won peter season i
don't even remember um
no maddie no he went back yeah that was
that was actually that was the season
that did it for everyone and hannah ann
and madison are famous because of like
the work that they've done on instagram
so stunning but
they could have easily just they weren't
they didn't get the winner's treatment
jackie you're so right ari linedak could
have pulled a peter webber but instead
he gave becca
a career yeah i know that's mean to say
but he did yeah he yeah he well he
elongated her career he in this space
yeah because she never she might not
have been the bachelor if they had just
pretended to date for two months someone
else would have gotten picked
yeah
so
just something to think about everyone
anyways
blake and katie
blady is over that's really i don't know
it's just i think i found it to be
really shocking yeah
i don't really care
you don't care no okay well our next
story is some more bachelor news you
know some happy couple news former
bachelor host chris harrison is engaged
to lauren zema
the former bachelor host announced on
instagram on monday that he's engaged he
unveiled the news by sharing a sweet
photo from the proposal which took place
at brand vineyard in napa valley
california so chris harrison has given
out his final rose how long were you
waiting to say that not very long i like
it's just the obvious no this is cute
like
can we move on like like you can't even
like no socio like
so cute love what else is there to say
i'm so happy for them yeah
she's a nice girl he's like it's great
yeah you could say that about really any
engagement news but just because he was
like the love doctor yeah no but they
were like dating for a long time what
happens next you get a cage like i just
i have like no feelings about this like
that's amazing news oh my god oh no i'm
not being [ __ ] i i actually scanning
my mind for one other thing to say and i
can't
like what is he up to these days i'm
sure he had a lot of time to search for
a ring he doesn't have a job he's boy
with no job yeah okay so we'll move on
no because i don't want to hurt you any
further i actually had one more thing to
say do you think he's gonna ever get a
job again
um if another network has a like a
dating show they should hire him they
should hire him just because like it
would be so much press for the show yeah
that's a good point
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
and you know what time it is
because we've been
separated
it's the final why aren't you doing it
with me i am going to comment on the
dues it's the final story
that was also a big one scoozy
okay our fifth and final story is a
little
oh ben's rendition of the final story
like blew up our broke the internet it
broke the internet he has such a big
head because like these last couple days
like pictures of him the clips you've
been posting which by the way you've
been really maintaining my flow thank
you so much for i know people thought i
stepped out of line no i thought you did
too but i said
i know i had a plan the engagement on
our instagram has just been like
literally double what it normally is
because it's you know we post the same
[ __ ] every day and it's something
different
and
he's literally gonna leave me like
he is such a big head
also just reminded me we need to post
one more thing should i do it now i had
an idea of oh they wanted to see italian
theo
okay but also no no you're not posting
that a selfie okay an italian theo
italian i got like such bad pictures and
these italian theo started barking like
really did not enjoy what i was offering
right but i no but ben explained that on
the show that he looks really scared so
everybody was like so excited to see
this oh obviously everyone didn't see my
instagram story because i posted so much
italian theo content oh so then we saw
it that
yeah but we want you with him maybe do a
slide okay okay and then we're gonna i'm
on it i'm on you can why don't you just
chat with the peeps for a little while
i'm gonna share the fifth and final
story if that's if you can keep one ear
open i'm here
kristen stewart says she's only made
five really good films and surprisingly
they're not twilight one twilight two
twelve three twelve eight four and
twilight five no they are those are
those are the five no she's her own
biggest critic and she says i've
probably made five really good films out
of 45 or 50 films ones that i go wow
that person made a top to bottom
beautiful piece of work
for her to say that like about about 45
films that didn't make the cut she only
name dropped two movies that she thinks
are those really great films clouds of
styles maria and personal shoppers so
then the other three
are you know up for debate and i would
say it would be twilight one
breaking dawn part four and five and
breaking dawn part two i would agree
here's the thing and i think that's what
she meant to she's doing promo for
spencer so like wouldn't she have
included spencer in that
well maybe like this leaves it open to
spencer is one of those potentially
wouldn't she have said it if she's doing
press for it
if it were the case like she's trying to
sell tickets like
yeah that's true the two movies that she
named i had never heard of or seen
and honestly like hearing her
probably say that she doesn't like think
that the twilight movies are that good
makes me really upset because what are
the odds that any of the twilight movies
are actually those remaining three like
honestly zero okay maybe just like
breaking down part two but um
no part one honestly
it's crazy because i imagine if you're
an actor like you do a lot of movies you
read a lot of scripts but you don't wind
like the odds that you wind up in a
movie that is a perfect like a work of
art you know just as she described like
a great movie i'm proud to be a part of
this and something that will like live
on for a very long time the odds of that
are really slim so when you get
something like that
especially if you do like 45 or 50
movies that's a big deal now the two
movies she mentioned i never heard of
yet she was in five movies that i have
heard of twilight is really that good no
i know and like that's what i'm saying
i'm gathering that she doesn't agree
with us it's gonna live on for it better
it's just like when i was watching the
brittany murphy documentary and how her
first movie role was ty frazier and
clueless oh wow yeah she did a lot of tv
before that but that was her first movie
and it's like that movie will stand the
test of time like she was and but what's
crazy about brittany murphy i would say
she was in about three movies that are
that uptown girls uptown girl eight mile
and clueless also just married that's
really good you know what before you set
up town girl i was going to say just
marriage but it's her best work it is
that and it's dakota dakota fanning's
best work so i think that kristen
stewart actually should be on to
something about like someone who's like
a really storied actress has five good
like five
iconic movies but then you know what i
think about i think about how like every
year for the last like 10 or 15 years
every movie that leonardo dicaprio has
been in it's like the best movie of all
time you know because like wolf of wall
street django so like the revenant i
didn't like it but it is like world
renowned that's what he won the oscar
for titanic shutter island and then even
like random what's eating gilbert grape
like
how is it that there's kristen stewart
but then there's also leonardo dicaprio
who every single movie he's ever done
is the best movie ever you know do you
have any bad movies catch me if you can
the best movie ever like find me a bad
leonardo dicaprio well you just said the
one that's coming out on netflix doesn't
look good it doesn't but again i haven't
seen it so that's really not fair to
assess yeah i wonder how is it the leo
or is it the script choosing
right you know it's a chicken and egg
situation is he making the movies great
or is he choosing great movies that's
such a good call no but the movie like
django
was like this gorgeous quentin tarantino
movie like
of course it was great with leonardo but
it would have been great without him too
yeah no jamie foxx was excellent in that
once upon a time in hollywood inception
oh great gatsby the departed blood
diamond oh no
that movie really [ __ ] with me i know
but it was so good so good the aviator
gangs of new york wow i'm telling you
see yeah yeah
like what would you say is leonardo
dicaprio's best movie
well i think it's a very subjective
question yeah let us know what you think
leonardo dicaprio's best movie is
honestly i would say
cheddar island
but only i think it was his best acting
because no i think his best acting was
what's eating gilbert rape oh that's
true but shutter island like it was it
was all dependent on he sold the story
it was a great story but like yeah it
could have been like tacky like acting
in shutter island was his best acting
but it wasn't his it's not the best
movie because there's so many others and
also because the concept of shutter
island is could be like a cliche
psychological thriller but he made it
like this oscar-worthy moment yes yes
and he acted as you know these two
people yeah multiple personalities yes
an interesting you know bit of acting
craft discussion and you know the actor
is it the script let us know yeah is it
the chicken or the egg
you know what's so great what today's
show's not over because it's tuesday and
that means it's your toaster's day and
we got three submissions from toasters
in need of our help and i think real
real
help is on the way because dear toast is
here and dear toasters is brought to you
oh by solo stove oh this is exciting we
were talking about them last week so if
you want to upgrade your backyard do it
with a solo stove fire pit you enjoy the
warm ambiance the mesmerizing flames and
all the opportunities to create more
good moments and lasting memories make
the time with your friends and family
richer with a solo stove fire pit okay
we just got one obviously we don't have
backyards but olivia does so she's
coming to town and we're sending her
home with this solo stove and when i was
in vermont with my friends we used a
solo stove and everybody was like raving
about it because it's a it's a better
fire pit they built a better mousetrap
explain they are brilliantly engineered
and beautifully crafted made with
premium 304 stainless steel and a
patented 360 degree airflow system that
maximizes efficiency while minimizing
smoke it's easy to light with a few bits
of starter because you know what
i one time burned all my eyelashes off
in utah trying to set on like this gas
it was so true outdoor fire it was crazy
it wasn't a solo stove and it should
have been um it's easy to light with
just a few bits of starter your fire is
blazing in minutes and it's perfectly
portable so you can take solo stove with
you on camping trips and more so if
you're outdoorsy you have a backyard you
don't have a fire pit in your house this
is so easy and it's it's so pretty
looking that's the other thing get the
perfect fire pit for those fall nights
and your chili and make your backyard a
destination with a spectacular fire pit
from solo stove shop the fall event now
and get an extra 10 off when you use
promo code toast at checkout they're so
confident that you'll love it that
they're offering a lifetime warranty and
a 30-day free return policy go to solo
stove solostove.com
remember get the ten dollars when you
use promo code toast like i don't want
to be pushy but if you have a backyard
and you don't have a solution you need a
fire pit and the solar stove is the
easiest fire pit you just plop it down
and you know we have we have fire and
then you come out with a chili like i'm
sorry you're just living my dream 100
all right first up claudia and jackie so
i have a boyfriend we've been together
for almost four and a half years we're
from the same hometown we've essentially
been in a long-distance relationship for
the majority of our time together
besides the summer and breaks from
school we're the same age he's finishing
undergrad and i'm in grad school he's
not a big phone guy we don't
consistently text anymore and we
basically rely on snapchat to
communicate daily cringe i know i hope
this isn't considered crazy and please
call me if it is please call me out if
it is but i rely on my find my friends
to know what he's up to it helps me ease
my spiraling thoughts when he hasn't
reached out in a few hours and i check
his location and see he's at the library
studying or out at a bar on the weekend
or hanging with his friends that is at
their house when i can have more context
for what's going on in his life i find i
have more grace for why he isn't
responding or prioritizing me since last
week his location has read no location
found have you spoken to him like is he
dead
um
i think he may have just turned off
location services altogether or need to
update his phone who knows but it
doesn't read that he has stopped sharing
his location with me so i know that he
probably has no idea that i can't see it
anymore i don't think he necessarily
knows how often i check his location but
he definitely knows that i can use it
for example the last time he's his
location stopped working was the one
time he lost his phone and needed me to
help him find it which obviously didn't
work because i found my friends was not
working i'm trying to gauge if i bring
it up to him
that his location hasn't been working
when we face time next or do i wait
until he visits me next month to tell
him in person does he know that she
tracks him she knows that he knows that
he has her location but he doesn't know
that she's checking it every day got it
um so she said do i see [ __ ] it and live
like the old days where we didn't have
this type of technology as a resource
what if he loses his phone again and i'm
of no help should i admit how much i use
find my friends or just say i happen to
see it wasn't working just 20 21
problems thank you ladies ps congrats on
all the achievements of tmt enlog bebes
spritz society thank you thanks girl
okay i want to say one thing before we
give you advice
and this might be hurtful
but it really doesn't sound like you
have much of a relationship you're in a
long-distance relationship where you
barely hear from the person and it's one
thing to not
be oh i'm not good with my phone but a
boyfriend like you gotta talk to your
boyfriend yeah i just think outside of
the find my friends you should demand
more of his attention
that's that's that's the first thing
that's an interesting point cause i'm
hearing from her of course she's
checking the location she's desperate
for something yeah and he's giving her
nothing like she's in a relationship
with find my friends yeah and like it's
one thing to not be good with your phone
not everyone is going to be like us i
can understand yeah but to not call
every couple hours it's your boyfriend
like yeah
for five years so i just maybe it took
another person seeing this from the
outside to let you know like you deserve
more than that i hadn't even seen i
hadn't even thought of it like that i
was just like thinking of the actual
logistics of how you're gonna tell him
that his location turned off but i also
think that you
are relying on it way too much and maybe
it's stymieing communication because you
know you don't need to if you see he's
at the library you're not going to ask
him what's up but maybe if you asked him
what's up it would spark a conversation
but think of the alternative like she
drives herself crazy because he doesn't
answer yeah so she's like what's up
anybody's an answer always [ __ ]
something you're in a relationship with
find my friends you're in a relationship
with his location you're having a
conversation with where are you i'm at
the library how long are you there for
i'm watching no literally because she
has to no i know but like you said which
i didn't even realize like that's not
much of a relationship you don't have an
overall relationship because distance
relationships are
all about communication they're mostly
about communication so if you have the
distance but you don't have the
communication what do you have find my
friends and now she doesn't have that
anymore so of course she's quaking so
honestly i don't even think it's about
to find my friends i think it's like
about
your relationship in general not that it
can't be fixed but like you really
when he comes to visit i don't think you
should be
focused on how to tell him about his
location you should be focused on saying
i don't not getting enough out of this
relationship yes but if you want to i
think you could you should do these two
things separately like first be like
you know text him one time hey what's up
where are you at if he doesn't respond
for a very long time then you can when
you do speak to him say by the way i saw
that you're fine my friends wasn't
working i was nervous because i didn't
hear from you right so just go about it
like you just discovered it in a very
benign way and then also i would
find the time and the words to have a
conversation about the larger us yeah
but you know if you have a man or a
woman or anyone and you don't have their
location like you ain't living not
because i don't trust ben but because i
don't trust ben when he says he's
outside wait when he says i'm five
minutes away no he's like i'm at the
light come down when he's picking me up
in the car
really you're six blocks up town right
how are you at the light right that's
why you should have everyone's location
yeah
okay next you're not wasting time no
your time is so valuable like you could
be listening to episodes of the toast
and signing up for patreon patreon.com
morning toast
claudia and jackie i've been a toaster
for a little over a year thanks to bobby
bones and his wife being fans and
mentioning you guys on his show thanks
bobby oh my god thanks bobby so happy to
have found you love the podcast anyways
i am happily married to my high school
sweetheart his name is ben and we have a
seven month old seven month old babe
girl who we adore i'm an icu nurse on a
coveted unit like many hospitals my unit
is extremely short staffed so we have a
lot of travel nurses on my floor we
recently got this new guy let's call him
zach
there's something about zack that i'm
just so drawn to he's cute funny and
just an all-around cool guy he's so easy
to talk to he's a huge sports fan as am
i whereas my husband hates professional
sports i find myself hoping he's working
on the days that i'm working and when we
are working together i talk to him we're
asking for help with tasks over other
people
um
this past weekend a co-worker through a
fall themed party sounds so funny
was it a fall harvest she threw a fall
theme party for all of our work friends
i went out of my way to invite him and
didn't invite any of the other travel
nurses
so here's my question what the [ __ ] is
wrong with me i love in a door ben but
i've never found myself really this
interested in another guy since i've
been with my husband almost 10 years i
would never cheat on ben and zach knows
i'm happily married but i also kind of
get the vibe that he's into me too
should i try and stay away from zach is
there anything wrong with a little
innocent workplace flirting is this
normal i don't want to be a bad wife
please help thanks so much love a nurse
with a dilemma
first of all thank you for your service
and second of all i don't know i feel
like it's fine you know what like i
think it's fine like you if you really
believe like you would never cheat on
your husband yes you know a little
workplace flirting like i'm it's it
makes it more interesting and you guys
are obviously working in very serious
circumstances so if you can find the
little brightness in your day just make
sure it doesn't go too far
but
i think i think it's okay and i think i
think it'll play itself out you know
like you know what like as always the
shiny new toys that we should shiny and
new and as like a woman when you get
older like you just like want more
attention like no matter who it's like
she's a seven month old and she's just
like out and someone thinks she's
interesting like go for it go for
talking to them and enjoying your life
in a very platonic harmless flirting
for a woman is fine
oh my god if the role if ben is flirting
with his wife while you have a seven
month old
i'm coming to the house i'm coming to
the office and i'm burning it down and
i'm terminating your employment 100
for for you totally fine you're a nurse
you work hard you work hard you deserve
a little flirtation i think it's totally
fine as long as you know where the line
is and there is a very clear line
but just you know have fun live a little
all right final one dear jackie and
claudia and theo and rutaru
i've always wanted to have a reason to
write into dear toasters and now i
finally do i've been dating a p john for
almost three years he's 31 and i'm 26.
he recently bought his own house and i
live separately my lease ends in june
and i started thinking about moving in
with him once that happens everything in
our relationship has been going smoothly
until a literal bomb was dropped just
days ago his sister in her late 20s is
moving in with him
she usually lives with his mom but
circumstances have changed chaotically
and my pgm boyfriend asked her if she
wanted to move in i plan to move in soon
but who wants to live with her with your
boyfriend and his grown sister i
initially agreed to the sister moving in
situation thinking it would be a very
short term moment but she already came
to look at the house her new room and
talked about all the decor and
reorganizing she's gonna do
two days later she's completely moved in
her decorations are everywhere she's
hung pictures on the wall put curtains
up completely reorganized every draw on
the house to the way that she wants it
my boyfriend is really ocd he didn't
even want me hanging things up when i
moved in to decorate when he moved in to
decorate sorry so when i saw her
completely take over the house it seemed
like she's staying more permanently than
my initial thought i don't have a
brother so i don't know what type of
bond but it just doesn't seem normal who
just completely takes over their
brother's new house and acts like the
girlfriend doesn't exist now i don't
want to be around now i don't even want
to be around his house especially not
around his sister because she
overstepped her boundaries and now i
just feel uncomfortable being in a house
that once felt like my own i don't want
to sound like a [ __ ] and say your
sister needs to move out but she's older
than me and needs to grow up and not
take over her brother's house how should
i go about this is this a red flag for
the future will this crazy family always
get in the way of our relationship or am
i just overreacting any advice is
appreciated well this is definitely an
obstacle but i'm gonna go operate on the
pretense that like you and this man are
otp and that the relationship is good
and that it's worth fighting for and i
don't know he's five years older than
you and like bought his own house
there's something worth like that is a
green flag
green
so my advice is to push your way in
there elbows get in there and when you
do move in in june and when he asks you
to move in hopefully he does it in a way
that's like romantic and a big deal and
then you just need to set some
guidelines your circumstances and you
say like so i would love to move in with
you like i'm crazy about you
but i just want there to be an
understanding like this is my home too
and so if it's your home too then you
can throw away her decor or you know get
rid of it because also like i hate to be
crass but like what's the rent situation
here right if you move in with him are
you helping with the mortgage is sister
paying any bills because if she's not no
bills no say no decor no i'm sorry like
i just think that if you're a grown
woman and you're living in your
boyfriend your younger brother's house
or maybe older i don't know who's older
you're living in he's older you're
living in your older brother's house and
his girlfriend moves in your time is up
yes but we can't fix this woman so i'm i
don't want to focus no i just wanted to
talk about the hoots but that is this
one of course putting up curtains of
course making herself known when she's
literally someone's doing her favor but
like from our purview of being just the
podcast giving advice to the girlfriend
who's trying to move in not not you nor
i know nor she can change the sister
that's true so all you can do is set up
the most comfortable situation for
yourself and hopefully
it makes the sister uncomfortable yeah
but june is a long time but i do think
that the best plan is definitely the
long game here
if he doesn't ask you to move in in june
get he's i'm done with him like yeah i
hate people who move slowly
you love me or not
he's [ __ ] his sister 100
if he doesn't ask you to move into june
you've got other problems but if he does
which we're expecting him fully to do um
you said i would love to your plan is
perfect it is your home you just on day
one you take out the curtains you put in
your curtains you get a rug you do
whatever you want and she'll feel
awkward cause like then it really is
like she's like living with her
like her parents you know she's like
kids that's the best piece of advice but
write us back in june if he doesn't ask
you to move in yeah because nothing in
this world nothing in this life is a
given yeah yeah but
you've got to set ground rules so that
like when you do those things if she
goes running to him that he knew that
you were going to do right like i only
agreed to move in with you and you're
you know um
you know i have a question for you
they said they said the word invalid in
crimea enthusiasm is that a bad word so
they did say that word yeah and i don't
think it's a kind word i don't think
it's a word we can say right because i
don't think it's a word you can just
throw around okay because i was gonna
especially like you know on the podcast
yeah okay i was just double checking
it's not a word we like are gonna use
it's like a it's a term but it's kind of
like a not a good one it's not nice okay
that's especially for someone who
is just a sister living with their
brother no i was trying to say like um
like
whatever i just dug myself into a hole
yeah but like uh she's just like living
off of the left yeah yeah so it's not
cool and you should just be
bossy yes exactly and you know your
comfort is her discomfort so just
make way that was beautiful make way
your comfort is her discomfort
um and her comfort is yours so your
discomfort so one of them maybe the more
discomfort
uncomfortable you make her feel the more
she'll want to leave right
so one of you is going to win and i
think you could be you yeah definitely
i'm on your side as long as they don't
have like a weird brother-sister thing
you never know and not even that they're
like actually doing stuff but like
sometimes brothers and sisters are weird
yeah um well that was your turn well
have you met cherise and joe judicia
also i don't know if you spoke about it
theresa's engaged we did speak about it
very happy for her yes and ben was very
excited for her really yeah he said he
loves the women of new jersey
yeah because he just recently started
the sports party yeah and
he was very excited very cool okay well
that was your toasters if you ever want
to write in it's dear toasters at
gmail.com
and if you've written in recently and
we've given you some bomb ass advice and
you have an update for us if things went
well if they didn't go well please we
would love to hear from you like we
would love to see how our prodigies are
doing out in the world you know dear
toasters at gmail.com that's our show
right that's all she wrote big hands
down everyone pens down
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast millennium morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast and where podcasts can be found
so it's spotify itunes stitcher public
radio i heart radio cast box all the
places wherever you listen to the
podcast find this morning totally five
star review about a beautiful stunning
and smart we are if you made it to the
end of the episode congratulations why
don't you drop on emoji on our most
recent instagram so let us know that
you're a true toaster um what are we
talking about today something italian
yeah the italian flag
sure the italian flag to celebrate
claudia's homecoming woo hoo and the
american one if you're a proud american
bye guys love you see you tomorrow for
hump day oh exciting